Kevin would have hosted it this year if
they wouldn't weren't trippin off of
things that he said in his past that he
already apologized for anything you know
I say a lot of things and I don't
apologize because no I think before I
speak if I say it I mean it Tiffany
Haddish speaking out about her good pal
Kevin Hart and the Oscars hosting
controversy on a UK talk-show Lorraine
like a brother I cut okay he's like
family
Kevin and Tiffany go way back he helped
her out financially before she hit it
big now I have attempted to repay that
man back at $300
four years now my $50 by the time I hunt
it out it's not nah you keep that and
give me all my money a month then I got
all the money I want and I tried to get
me some he's like nine now you invest
that back into yourself invest that in
your career Kevin was of course at the
hosted this year's Academy Awards but
ultimately dropped out after past
controversial comments of his resurfaced
guys almost 40 years old if you don't
believe that people change grow evolve
as they get older I don't know what to
tell you
if you want to hold people in a position
where they always have to justify or
explain their past and do you I'm the
wrong guy man I'm in a great place a
great mature place where all I do is
spread positivity if you're not doing it
you're not on my page now it's looking
like the 2019 show will go host list for
the first time in years do you know why
don't we get you guys to do the Oscars
that would be cool because you know how
they're looking for the host and they're
talking about not having a host and I
think he needs somebody to sort of link
it together well it would be nice to
have the gang in a yang there you know
if we did it together that would be cool
but you know any proper preparation time
you
[Applause]
[Music]